so it's just quick question so so so I
have a presentation I can do the
presentation
we're gonna have a discussion it just
wasn't clear which you prefer or shade
just do what I do I'll do me how do you
do okay so yes so I want to talk to you
about effectively this practice or this
approach to thinking about the future
that myself and some my colleagues in
the near-future laboratory and others
called design fiction and we look at it
as a way to effectively think about the
very tangible implications of the ideas
that I'm sure are in a lot of our heads
about possible futures or new ideas that
we have or ideas for innovation I'm
trying to represent those in a way that
from my point of view in my perspective
and I think other people share this
makes it feel a little bit more real
than as we were talking during during
the during the lunch session more real
than like a in abstract that might go
into a research proposal and I have to
believe and I have to feel that very
many of us so you have creative bright
sort of motivated by the possibility of
making a brighter better more habitable
future world that we we we don't think
in abstractions we think in the
implications that our ideas
ultimately are going to have in everyday
life and my trajectory professionally as
an engineer and as a researcher and as a
designer and as a as an academic has I
just sort of come to realize that I
prefer to work in tangible realities and
combining my you know my sort of my own
background and electrical engineering
computer science where it's like I like
to solder stuff and I like to look under
look under the microscope as I'm doing
like SMD placement I'm much more
interested in the nitty-gritty of the
everyday and actually making the things
that might exist in worlds than I am and
just you know doing an abstract for an
NSF proposal which is probably why I
didn't succeed as an academic so so the
subtitles it effectively gets down to
it's like how do we imagine the future
what are the ways in which we imagine
the future and it's a it's a genuine
question so I've got some answers to it
but understanding that we translate
these ideas that come to us and they
might come to us was walking down the
street it might come to us in a dream
might come to us as
do we see like a really good
science-fiction film with like hey
wouldn't it be cool if we try to
represent those abstract kind of things
in our imagination we articulate them in
some kind of way so we might answer that
question like wouldn't it be cool if dot
dot and then we answer the f and we tell
a story to our friends and it's like we
say things like we get you know almost
breathless like if but suppose it was
able to connect this way and then when
you're going over there it did some
other kind of thing and we begin to
represent them not just in abstractions
as sort of vague expressions of a
generalized idea but as the things that
we would experience and for me you know
sort of framing the question to say
great idea what does that look like when
I get up in the morning how does that
change what is the experience of having
that idea when I've lost one shoe in the
morning what does this mean for my
commute from home to work how is it
going to affect that and it actually
makes your work a bit thicker it makes
it a little bit more tangible than the
abstraction and it's almost like stop
working in abstractions just start
answering the everyday question tell the
story and add some drama to it so this
is it so we tell stories we tell stories
and we also do a lot of a lot of work a
lot of these ideas have represented in
film and if you think if anyone here you
know show a hands who is not a fan of
film who is not a fan of film with some
good drama in it who is not a fan of
good science fiction film oh okay sorry
what I've come to learn is that film in
particular is a very effective way of
telling a story and we know this from
some of the great cinematographers and
storytellers and film directors so you
know I'm a huge fan of Steven Spielberg
and I've learned a lot not from him
personally but I've learned a lot in the
way which he tells films and one of the
one of the sort of groundbreaking films
at least in terms of my sort of like
professional understanding of this was
Jurassic Park
so everyone remember the film Jurassic
Park so a world in which dinosaurs exist
so you know a amazing visual story you
know told effectively by Steven
Spielberg based on Michael Crichton's
book of the same name about a world in
which dinosaurs exist complete
like dinosaurs do not exist they might
have existed but they would they don't
exist now I'm almost positive that but
nevertheless you know I shelled out 11
bucks to go see a world in which they do
exist and if you remember the film the
sort of the syntax and the visual
structure of the film was absolutely
brilliant and you know I mean they knew
what they're doing so they know that an
audience is gonna comments like well
okay we'll see some dinosaurs running
around again it's kind of cool but
pretty sure that they don't exist but
the first the first beats of the film
are them effectively telling us and
showing us how they could exist and they
do it with science so if you remember
the beginning of the film they
effectively show us like that sort of
high school style science film it's
almost like it's playing on a 16
millimeter projector which they used to
exist I know because I was the guy who
pushed the card around to the room in
high school with them and they said they
showed like in a wonderful animated way
how dinosaurs
DNA can be reanimated when it's frozen
in amber and they sort of take us
through almost like just guiding us by
the hand as you would if you're telling
the story to a child about how they do
this but they're telling it to us it's
not for the sake of you know in
advancing the story as much as helping
us as an audience come to suspend
disbelief about the existence of
dinosaurs at least so we get you know
$11 worth of entertainment experience
and understanding that powerful way in
which a story can be told
help someone suspend their disbelief if
only for the purposes of you know having
enjoying it
dramatic film to me was just it just
changed my my view about what it is to
do and tell stories about the future so
you do it in such a way that you can
guide someone through it and say like
this is what the world would look like
now we know it's just fiction but for
this moment we're gonna allow you to
enjoy that and so finding the way in
which you can sort of apply that same
approach to storytelling particularly
with like little films for me became a
very important aspect of this design
fiction work and this came through a
academic friend colleague I called David
Kirby professor at at University of
Birmingham where he was looking at
effectively almost you know giving a
number of examples in which this
particular approach to telling a story
is used but then he went one step
further he said not only is it used he's
saying it's being used for purposes
beyond just that moment of like you know
two hours of enjoyment so he gives it an
example of a film called destination
moon and in destination moon the
producers of the film basically
commissioned it because they wanted to
tell a story about man going to the moon
and it was still at a time where that
was like very high speculation but they
were actual investors so they wanted to
fund an industry that would actually
build up around this idea of trying to
get to the moon so how they do what they
do as a documentary they do as a kind of
corporate video to say this is how we'll
do it they did it as drama so they did
it as if you you can find it on YouTube
it's a bit it's it's quirky and a little
bit hokey you might say the special
effects aren't that great so to get it
to look like the guys that they're in
zero gravity
obviously they just tilt through the
camera to the side and they had the guy
walk kind of in a clunky way across this
floor in order to get out of the
spacecraft so spacecraft is one of those
cigar-shaped things that lands on a
tripod which is that you know it's a you
know bit impractical to get out they
lower ladder down so little hokey things
like that but they went through the
purpose of actually showing the steps
and you would have to do and they show
some of the implications of like space
travel again in a kind of corny way so
that they're they're bored because it
takes a long time to get from the earth
to the moon and so they sit around like
a prison chain-gang one guys playing a
harmonica to pass the
and they're passing around cheese
sandwiches because people you know
astronauts got to eatin out of space but
they answer the questions that a large
public audience would have like what
would it be like to travel to the moon
they don't just go there they show like
almost in a laborious way like all the
things that they would need to do as
almost as a guidebook so the saying
these are the thing these are the
questions we're gonna have to answer
these are the sort of challenges that
industry is gonna have in order to be
able to get there and so for me that
became like a way what David calls out
the diegetic prototype so diegetic is
from the greek die jesus meaning sort of
narrative and story and the prototype is
the thing that you build it's the
representation of something that is
possible but almost done a material form
and David would point at all these
different aspects of these films like
destination moon and Jurassic Park and
2001 a Space Odyssey and say these are
prototypes of possibility and what what
happens when you do that really well is
that you begin to communicate to a large
scale public all the audience the
possibility of this idea so it's clever
marketing effectively it's a clever way
of enrolling people into your vision of
a possible world and it's it's something
that you know initially as a very
pragmatic unless pragmatic now as a
pragmatic kind of instrumentally minded
engineering kind of guy I'd be like
that's just marketing it doesn't really
help me with my problem doesn't help me
translate my idea into to other people's
experience but I've come to learn that
it actually does if you can tell a story
that helps people understand the idea
that's in your head that maybe you're
having a little trouble describing or
expressing with words maybe you're
having a little trouble getting people
to see your frustration getting people
to see what's in your imagination
turning it around and telling a story
especially a visual one can be a very
powerful way of doing it one of the one
of the you know one of one of David's
conclusions through through this well it
was as a paper but then it became a book
called lab coats in Hollywood where he
doesn't do a whole bunch of different
examples of this is that that it may be
much more powerful than than just you
know writing a research report
and I've come to realize that because
research reports really don't get read
so this is what design fiction is he saw
the use of dye jet ik prototypes to
suspend disbelief about the future so
telling stories with objects that
somehow represent your idea in order to
get people to sort of say like huh okay
I see what you're talking about
I can see that world and for us I think
it's it's it's almost crucial to make
that representation where we sort of
call the normal ordinary everyday so not
the big macro scale stuff not you know a
world in which but more like again like
I'm saying what is it like - how do I
get my dog to come back when when it's
run and chasing a squirrel like the
experiences that we know everyone has
what do i do my connoisseur we were
amusing about these possible examples
what do I do when a self-driving car has
blocked my driveway or I left a bag of
groceries in the self-driving car and
it's gone off to pick someone else up or
I left my kid in the self-driving car
because I was kind of distracted by
something else these are things that we
know will happen and it's almost like
rather than doing it rather than you're
looking at the edge cases not so much to
say like we've identified the edge cases
but doing it because it makes you travel
back to the core problem and it actually
expands the problem set and it helps
define the problem set in a more robust
way and I'll give you some examples so
at the near future laboratory we're
working on what we're calling the manual
they probably won't be called that but
we call something like that where we
effectively go through what design
fiction is historically where it came
from sort of people who sort of working
in and around it and then probably most
effectively as a manual is to describe
what we call design fiction archetypes
so these are frameworks around which
design fictions can inhabit and sort of
become come to life it's not it's not a
you know exclusive list it's meant to be
you know sort of like almost motivating
some other possible ideas but some of
the ones that we enjoy so you know films
obviously we love telling stories
through images repair manuals because
things in every world need to be
repaired so if you if you have an idea
like what is it what you know and you
have to do these things I worked in
Nokia and my own company now we're
making products and yet those products
need a way in which the the the largest
system outside of like the wonderful
world way in which all your consumers
are going to enjoy it someone's gonna
say like well that bit broke so what do
I do and by beginning to actually
construct those kinds of things those
repair manuals you understand more
thoroughly what it is that you're
building QuickStart guides big fan of
those because that's a very concise way
because QuickStart guides are meant to
be quick and short in which you can
describe what it is that you're trying
to build or create and product
catalogues big fan of product catalogs
because those are one of the ways in
which things almost become like oh if
it's in a catalog it must really exist
and you're forced to answer a whole
bunch of questions that you might not
otherwise even address or even consider
how much does it cost where is it
manufactured is a manufacturer in a
bunch of different places how do you
describe it what kind of currency do you
accept you can set Bitcoin and why do
you accept Bitcoin what does it look
like and in in in a product catalog kind
of way not just like a napkin sketch so
you know actually being being thorough
about the problem and making it bigger
and it's it's not so much the conclusion
of the work that is interesting although
I think you know making it really
compelling and kind of cool and maybe
even a little bit confusing to people
because they're like wait is this real
if that's that's really exciting stuff
but it forces you to do the things that
you would have to do anyway so if
someone said like what colors does it
come in as an engineer might say like
color doesn't matter whatever whatever
people like but if someone says you got
to answer that question you begin to
consider like well what color would it
be and why would it be those colors you
begin to understand what it is that
you're creating in a much more thorough
way so here's an example of one of my
favorite design fiction moments so we
might say this is a design fiction for
augmented reality so absolutely is super
important film very important to watch
they live John Carpenter 1989
ninety-eight so rowdy roddy piper famous
action hero gets these glasses and they
show the world in a different way he
puts them on No
[Music]
hey what's that and so this is you know
before ogni oh well I guess maybe in and
around early kind of almost like more
science fictional than science fact
representations of augmented reality but
a remarkable way in which this very this
very simple idea that there could be
this alternate world and we're just not
seeing it but if we had some kind of
affordance that allowed us to see it
what would that world look like is an
abstract question I mean I'm trouble
saying it but if you begin to show it's
like well let me just show you what I
mean in some kind of way begin to
understand what the possible
implications were of course this is just
a just a crazy zombie attack film but
it's but it you know it has these it had
its sort of thickens the problem space
so it's not just about wayfinding and
it's not just about you know all the
other things that Google glass may have
been if it wasn't just sort of like a
not thoroughly considered idea but it
begins to tell a story about a world in
which this actually exists and someone
might say someone clever at Google might
say like Oh brilliant we can have like
multiple forms of advertising because
this thing's can be able to show things
because it's gonna be able to do kind of
scene recognition that's a great idea
thanks for making this film you gave me
a new idea or it might be someone saying
like actually it's might be a little bit
squirrely because other people seeing
other things that other people next one
weren't seeing might have implications
for pedestrian foot traffic people might
get distracted by something that they're
not that that someone else isn't seeing
so all these kinds of things begin to
bubble out and by having by forcing
yourself to kind of go through it not
just imagining that or describing it to
a friend but say I'm like right who's
got a camera we're gonna take two hours
make a quick film I'm gonna get mad
after-effects do a quick at it and by
six o'clock tonight we'll have something
we can share and talk about is a
powerful way of developing and evolving
your ideas another super important film
everyone must have seen this I hope 2001
a Space Odyssey 1968 Stanley Kubrick and
arthur c clarke telling a story about
interplanetary space travel
for we even got to the moon so they're
doing this at the same time that space
programs in the US and the Soviet Union
are in full swing which is must been an
absolutely remarkable time to actually
make a film about space travel and it
was so remarkable that Stanley Kubrick
being Stanley Kubrick and the kind of
character that he is decided to hire
actual rocket scientists away from space
programs to help him with the production
design so the spacesuits that you see in
2001 a Space Odyssey some of the
materials that they try to represent in
the structures of the spacecraft we've
came from actual rocket scientists so it
wasn't just an artist saying like well I
think it should look something like this
it was actual rocket scientists who were
designing spacesuits saying actually
this is sort of what it looks like and
here are the reasons why and when I say
Stanley Kubrick being Stanley Kubrick I
mean a guy who's like you know his
representations of worlds he's not just
like he's a kind of guy he wouldn't say
like good enough that's good enough
that's not good enough
it's got to be thorough I have to feel
like this is representing a possible
world and even down to the detail you
know details that you see here at that
point you know you would take for
granted that IBM would be involved so
there's an IBM logo in there he's got
graphical user interfaces before there
was even that expression graphical user
interface so representing these things
in ways that you know if you've anyone's
seen like Mission Control from back in
the day it was mostly tech stuff and
people doing ASCII art effectively to
try to represent graphs and those sorts
of things he just goes a step further
and that's him collaborating with
amazing production designers to create
these things and it's not easy stuff so
there was no CGI they actually had to
make the film that represented these
screens and then rear project them to
show them and all the things that he
does you know just in just the the level
of detail in this stuff is is
mind-boggling and in my mind this is
sort of a you know this this is a
prototype of graphical user interface
not just cuz he's showing it but he's
showing humans involved in it into the
procedure some people might say was sort
of a laborious scene of just trying to
get docking a ship to the space station
it goes on for about 20 minutes but he
shows that he's thorough about it he
shows all the complexities that might be
involved in how the displays interact
with the relative motion of the
different objects and all the kinds of
amazing visual
scene so this was one of the original
movie posters from 2001 a Space Odyssey
you know so we see like activities
something going on the moon couple
astronauts are sort of doing
looks like scientific sort of stuff
they're studying things reviewing notes
but they have that thing they're some
kind of tablet II iPad II looking thing
remember this is 1968 so it might not be
hard to speculate that people would
represent information on something other
than you know piece of paper and a
clipboard if they're in out of space
might be something sort of techie and
it's probably a screen of some sort so
you know the remarkable imagination
again sort of represented here and here
are the two astronauts in zero-g eating
horrible-looking food also looking at
these kind of I patty looking things
kind of cool you know again just that
ability to kind of sit down with a bunch
of production designers in a good
creative team and so if technicians and
that kind of stuff like how would we see
things in the future and say like well
you know probably be like this
television thing that we have now only
much more compact and sort of portable
in that case that's how hard you can
extrapolate things along those kind of
usual instrumental dimensions smaller
lighter cheaper faster bah bah bah bah
bah but then this happens which blew my
mind so when Samsung and Apple went to
court
Samsung cited 2001 Space Odyssey in
legal terms as precedents for dismissing
the case that Apple was the innovator of
this kind of iPad II thing they
literally pointed to that YouTube video
that I just showed you in a legal
document so it's not just me up here
saying like oh you know like sometimes
film sort of like shapes the material
world and has implications and things
like jurisprudence you know that has
huge implications in our lives so if a
court makes a decision it affects us in
in ways that our very material means we
pay more money for something or means
that you know if Samsung had won this
case that maybe Apple would be you have
to get into a different line of business
like real material change in a world
half
because a science-fiction film yeah I
mean this is like heavy stuff
Samsung didn't win because apples got
better lawyers or something so here's
that here's a little film that we made
and I'll just let it play and then we
can talk about it it's just a little
snip from the film
so what happened there is that the
recognized because she had different
makeup on from its imprint of earth
call Gerardo Leland
call Jair do calling to hear to call
ended failed gesture recognition call
Jer rare do you - hey Gerardo sorry
yeah let's meet in like half an hour
Paul ended so this was a film sent from
a set of work that we did we called
curious rituals and we were just sort of
uninterested in studying the yeah just
the kind of everyday experiences we
would have in a world in which your
gesture and voice become a kind of
common everyday normal human way in
which we sort of interact with
algorithms out there and rather than
just sort of showing that bright
gleaming perfect future we wanted to
just show like what we all know at the
end of the day despite the brilliance of
our ideas despite the remarkable skills
of the builders of algorithms
doesn't work it just goes south and to
varying levels of degrees I'm very
sensitive to this maybe because I'm an
engineer you realize that you can't
solve all the problems nor would you
necessarily be expected to and I think
it's that expectation that kind of
throws things off a little bit this work
is not meant to say we shouldn't do this
stuff but we shouldn't pursue it it's
meant again to sort of broaden out your
understanding of the implications of the
work so that you can make the work
better and it doesn't mean that you you
know you have to like okay so Gerardo I
should build in a better you know
recognition for names that are not us
English maybe it does but it also
represents this idea that you almost
bring you a little bit of humility to
the work that we do rather than hubris
like we have this remarkable you know
expectation
to create a much better world but we're
just humans ourselves and so the
implications of our work isn't always
going to aren't always going to be
absolutely perfect and so doing this
work you know it's almost like a
conversation starter to again sort of
like broaden out the definition of the
problem that we're trying to solve and
just go through the work of saying like
you know again inserting a bit of
humility into your understanding of what
you're trying to accomplish to say
rather than just trying to solve this
problem I'm gonna tell a little story
about a world in which this you know my
ideal solution exists and just do that
really really quickly like don't be
overly Precious about it but also be
like oh come on I know that when I reach
for the alarm clock I don't always hit
it I sometimes knock it off the table so
what is that same kind of gesture how
does that operate in the world in which
maybe you just tell the alarm to turn
off you say what's she called Alexa it's
the Alexa stop the alarm and a left
Alexa either misunderstands you or the
Wi-Fi has gone down so Alexa just sits
there spinning and the alarm still going
off and just sort of running those
stories through plus it can be fun and
funny
I think repair manuals is another
favorite idiom anyone know what this is
actually you do yes Star Trek
communicator this was from a I think
with Sotheby's auction catalog so it was
actual prop that was used you guys just
a prop so someone someone crafted it
made it into a thing they use some
materials that they found around he's
probably talked about kind of what it
should be like sort of walkie talkie
like that sort of thing so this is a
Star Trek start at Star Trek Starfleet
technical manual remember I got one of
these when I was about 11 years old
maybe it's like I would wanted it so
badly my dad made me wait until there
was a Star Trek convention because he
was like you know we just knew would be
cheaper there than it would be at the
local book store and so I waited I got
it
somebody got called friends Joseph at
the time and you know like 11-year old I
was just like this is just technical
manual for this this show that I'm
really into and it's going to show me
the technical details of the show like
how this
works super naive but it sort of did
like it had this level of detail on
levels like veracity that was really
compelling like this isn't just like a
you know production still of William
Shatner with a communicator this is like
technical stuff like I can tell by you
know it's got it's got a plan view it's
got sort of like call-outs in a
particular style that represents you
know instrumental utility like telling
you what parts are and that kind of
thing
scale showing you what colors things go
oh what the heck a schematic are you
kidding me like you know with me like at
that time I was like you know starting
to build circuits I was like there it is
done deal I can build one and it's you
know absolutely looks right look it's
got crystals for each one of the
channels remember those that were like
created youthful crystals it's got three
transistors bunch of switches a battery
of course it makes absolutely perfect
perfectly good sense look it's even got
a parts list amazing so this was a book
this guy like I said franz josef wrote
so it was it was a New York Times
bestseller which is amazing Franz
Josef's was an aerospace draftsman in
Southern California so he had that kind
of technical mechanical skill to kind of
draw these things he was also obviously
a fan of Star Trek and he just took upon
himself independent of you know of CBS
and the whole Star Trek universe to just
basically make this so he just sat down
I imagine him in his evenings with draft
table with a glass of port next to him
and just kind of like you know music
playing and he's just sort of drawing
these things what would this actually
look like and it became it was a kind of
thing that was circulated amongst the
Star Trek fan universe at at trade shows
and conventions and it's something that
and you know the world today we take for
granted that you know entertainment
enterprises would kind of know but they
CBS didn't know that this was going on
until it kind of bubbled up and they're
just like wait what the heck and at that
point they had canceled the show but
once they realized that there was this
whole kind of like you know subculture
as they
would have called the back ban of people
who is actually engaged in expanding the
fiction of the universe that they
created they actually rebuilt you know
they brought through franchise back
which is I absolutely remarkable you
know what this is right
no one gets a prize for that one because
look at that the Haynes people made a
Emanuel repair manual for the Millennium
Falcon how cool is that so a Haynes
manual if you don't know they're just
you know remarkable franchise of of
workshop manuals so this is the one I
had for my VW Rabbit because I bought it
for five hundred bucks and spent all my
money and only way I could get it fixed
was to fix it myself so it just tells
you how to repay you know we all that
you know repair procedures for the fuel
injectors and suspension and everything
else you might need to deal with so they
very cleverly I'm not sure who did I
should find out decided that they would
just create these repair manuals for
these fictional things so like the
enterprise like oh yeah I got a I got an
old enterprise-d in the back lot and
it's kind of gotten problems with the
thrust injector how can I fix it and
they actually go through you know they
said they talked about the different
systems they kind of like depending on
which one they kind of vary between kind
of like describing a bit more the kind
of the the fictional universe so I'll
talk about you know different characters
and their kind of role that they play
and sometimes they'll actually delve
into things like you know people like
scientists and other people sort of
speculating about the Pala the
possibilities of warp travel whatever
that might be
you know really digging into like the
science behind it or just like fun stuff
like actually you know little schematics
and blueprints about the ships and what
they look like and it's just a way to
kind of like expand your and invest your
imagination into it this is one of my
few know so Apollo 11 that actually
exists but I love that you know I can
have like an only workshop manual for
what I think is one of the most amazing
vehicles ever ever built quick start
guys is another area so at one point we
were doing a catalog project and we it
was around the car we called the cat car
Al Gore and as you know Google's
self-driving car of some sort we had a
description of and that kind of thing
and then we thought like well that
didn't feel like quite enough what if we
just did a workshop when we made a
QuickStart guide for the self-driving
car I just thought that was absolutely
exciting because it's like yeah we like
the idea of like the salt
car-like in principle in general and we
think about the ways in which you might
you know help our lives and all those
kinds of things and be fantastic on long
road trips and all that stuff but what's
it going to mean for people when they
actually get it like what's the first
thing you know what are the things that
they're gonna the questions they're
gonna ask or the problems that they
might have that you need to be able to
describe in a very very concise way and
doing it in a concise way you forces you
to compact the problem down to just the
key elements so you can't get abstract
it's a job for people to do and people
who do QuickStart guides really really
well are worth their weight in gold
because they're able to take a complex
system like any point-and-shoot camera
is barely point-and-shoot I mean it's
got like menu systems that are
absolutely broke they're just like all
kinds of crazy stuff going on like I
just want to take a photo first of all
which one's the power button so just
being able to condense problems down to
like just that tangible moment in which
you first have it and need to operate it
and so just briefly describe so to do
this project first thing we did is we we
did you're working with some students at
CCA we did a almost the world in which
this exists represented in sort of
popular media media so we did you
imagining moments in which the car
exists like all kinds of things happen
in and around it so someone does a study
on the rise of the well-rested commuter
it's like all of a sudden people's
behaviors at work change because
actually they get a get it you know
another 30 minutes news on their way to
work how does that change in in form and
shape what it is to be like you know in
an office where most people come in and
maybe they're like a little bit agitated
because that one guy cut them off and
all those kinds of things all of a
sudden a people are happy homeless but
not Carles so people decide like
actually if my self-driving car an
infinite loop mode I can live in it I'll
just do laps around San Francisco it's
much cheaper than rent and so this
becomes another one of those
implications and you don't have to like
solve that problem or you just you just
say it in a headline and it gets people
thinking about like oh yeah that could
be one of the things that happen I could
totally imagine that all of a sudden
people find a way hack that hack
self-driving cars to do ramrod odds on
jewelers and all that kind of stuff so
people just sort of like say like oh
just try
that way as fast as possible because
they hacked it and now there's just this
raft of like burglaries of cars ramming
into jewelry shops and people just
running in and heist them yeah this
stuff will happen we know that you know
despite the fact people like ah it seems
a little far-fetched Justin Bieber drunk
falls asleep in the back of his car it
can't lose his GPS signal and just as
laps around Calabasas California with
him in at TMZ on the spot Amazon now
becomes the third biggest auto
manufacturer like sure I mean I could
see it there getting into everything so
this how'd you start so we started we'd
you know again with this the importance
of having the tangible result the thing
at the end of it is super important so
you don't just want to walk out of the
room with you know do you know forgive
me but like a stack of posted notes that
you then lose later you don't want to
just like walk out of the room with oh
that was an interesting conversation but
now I've got other things I got to deal
with you want to walk out with something
that becomes like a memento of the
experience that you still refer back to
something tangible that sits on your
desk not on a hard drive that you can
then say like yeah that was actually
there was a couple things in there I
still want to get back to I still want
to evolve and develop so we always
always always put you know the final
punctuation is here's the film it might
be three minutes here's the printed out
QuickStart guide it might be seven pages
here is the you know the kind of
MacGuffin II kind of object that we made
because we did a bunch of CAD and
printed something out in 3d that's
that's gonna remind us what we thought
talked about so you know do you guys
know what workshops look like people
sitting around sketching ideas out
there's me sitting a corner I got to
work on the frequently asked questions
which was super super fun and the the
overall sort of definition of the
problem was we you know from the in the
beginning we spent the first about 90
minutes saying what sections what are
the main systems that we need to address
what are the kinds of other aspects in
and around the world of self-driving
cars
we might need to explain to people aside
from just like you know get from point A
to point B so here's something section
so legal claims and priorities the the
IAI system ingress and egress how do you
get in and out how do you program a
route how do you do manual override this
thing is screwed up it's following ways
I know that left turn is no good it's
gonna there's a construction going on
down there and then the AV Entertainment
because like look if we're gonna be in
self-driving cars like yes just might
say like I'll get much more reading done
but when it comes down to everyone be
like oh car is for I want to see that so
how do you interact with those through
the systems like real world stuff people
divide it up into groups and then you
know you can starting to make it
tangible to show what would it look like
you know what are the different how do
we want to represent these different
systems how do we want to describe them
what's the what's the what's the you
know the on brand vernacular what's the
kind of language that we want to use
that expresses these ideas in a human
way and that's you know that's C you
know I've been involved in the company
that that you know now is where the ways
in which we communicate what we're doing
is super important obviously but we want
to do it in a particular way that forces
you to understand and come to films kind
of come to terms with what is the you
know what what is the who are you
communicating to and how do you want to
communicate to them what are the the
keywords that you want to use and it
almost makes it feel more real and so
then you know we said this is what we
ended up with so we you know we defined
a visual style this is a kind so we did
this workshop ran we had the rough thing
and then four of us sat down over about
90 minutes and just kind of you know
quickly pulled this together like very
simple visual style but again trying to
make it feel like and look like it's
it's a real thing like someone this is
the QuickStart guide for Amazon
self-driving car it's not an idea for a
QuickStart guide for a self-driving car
you can print it out and kind of like
bind it and sort of say like here this
is what it would look like so just go
through a few few pages so like parking
your car like is there is there a valet
mode so you actually put it in valet
mode the car stops you get out and then
it goes someplace
so just having that idea that this is
what you would do rather than just
saying like yeah probably it parks
itself you actually have to show it and
describe it and show people how to
operate it what button they need to
press how much time they have to get out
of the car all those kinds of things and
you start understanding the problem in a
much more rich way how do you call the
car back so if the cars gone in valet
mode if you're in Los Angeles who knows
where it might go you might be trying to
park like in Santa Monica and it might
be like I got to go to Hollywood in
order to stop moving because of some
kind of weird regulation in Santa Monica
so it's gonna say like you know how long
is it gonna take for you to get your car
back when should you actually call it
back aaron mode so this is like my
favorite so like god I want some pizza
but I don't want to get in the car I'm
already in my pajamas and my house
slippers like send the car to Pizza Hut
so that's cool but then like wait a
minute so if the car goes to Pizza Hut
where are they gonna put the pizza like
I don't want to put it inside first of
all I don't want them getting my car cuz
maybe I've left something valuable in
there that I'm just fine leaving there
but I don't want just them get in there
and then plus the car's gonna smell like
pizza so it's like oh so these cars
actually need like a valet food or item
trunk that someone can open up with a
special knock code okay brilliant cool
so they've got that so that's something
else got to tell the industrial
designers that they're going to need to
build that kind of system but then if
it's food like how do they keep the
pizza warm and how do they keep the
milkshake that come with the pizza from
melting uh so now it's got to have a
cold and a hot one and so you know so
you start running all these problems
through to a point where you're actually
doing the work of design and the product
rather than just saying like yeah I can
go get errands refresh so if your car if
you loan your car out because it's like
also got you have a contract with uber
that 40% of the time car needs ooh you
can take over your car so some people
might get into it and they might it
might be out during after hours and
someone might get sick in the car or
someone just might you know leave a bad
smell in it so it needs a system to be
able to refresh itself after we drive
and so you got to run through like how
do you do it so if it's gonna like
inject some kind of like freshener into
the car
it needs to give you a warning because
you don't want to get like covered in
this kind of refreshing er so running
through all those kinds of implications
again sort of enliven as a problem and
then you know sort of like that some of
the frequently asked questions there's a
whole fun list of them so things like
[Music]
can i jailbreak my my car and so you got
a cue like a long explanation about you
know why you can't do that and what the
possible legal implications can be can i
service my car myself like heck no and
do that it is you know sort of
interesting
I've left someone or something in my car
when I've sent it off in uber mode how
do I get them back my kid in the car
my groceries because I was confused and
all of a sudden just went off like with
that and so product catalogues I'm
damaged okay so so it's a super fan of
catalogues again because they they're
way what in which you can represent sort
of the like it the you get a sense of a
world in which um represented you have
clearly you know a kind of consumer
world by the by the things that are out
there so you're even just going through
Amazon you get a sense of like okay so
what you know it's almost like the
inverse of someone telling you the story
about the world's like let me just see
the kind of stuff that people buy and
I'll get a better sense of the kind of
world that it is and we go sort of a
step further because we want to try to
translate like big abstract ideas and
make them normal ordinary everyday by
abstracting them down to the point where
they're really commoditized so
artificial intelligences come in seventy
four cultures and comes in red green and
blue what is that world so not making
the kind of thing where it's just the
provenance of a few people who have
access to it but where literally I can
get an artificial intelligence for 99
cents and it lasts for seven days what
does that world look like when everyone
has access to these grand ideas and so
we'd like focus a lot on you know the
corner can be
so when we did the TBD catalog I'll give
away a few more got a group of us
together so science fiction writers
artists curators designers engineers
computer scientists film makers and we
basically sat in a room for a couple
days we had a little bit of stimulus
material and this is sort of like you
know maybe one of the larger design
fictive projects because I went over
three days rather than you know three
hours getting people to think about
combinations of things and what they
might look like so we use this kind of
deck of cards to say mix a wallet with
artificial intelligence plus
miniaturization like what are the what
is that what are the implications of
that taking broad themes and trying to
extrapolate them you know away from
again the abstract to like what does it
mean for the normal person who's just
you know trying to get a breakfast
sandwich again workshop stuff people
standing around looking at things
drawing pictures we we did it in Detroit
which is an amazing city just because it
exudes possibility it was a perfect
place to do this and we were fortunate
enough to spend a couple days at the
Henry Ford Museum and actually go into
the super secret dark archives where
they've got everything they've got every
McDonald and toy remember even
McDonald's used to give away toys like
they've got like drawers and drawers of
them they have Judy Garland's shoes from
Wizard of Oz they've got Nikolai Tesla
there's a whole barn filled with like a
bunch of his stuff which is amazing so
it's just as sort of like stimulus like
seeing the world of material objects the
stimulus and then we just you know we
basically constructed sort of like we'd
you know again having that one I have
that tangible that tangible in like
groups of two or three of us would just
have one particular product to focus on
and had to do everything so again just
over emphasizing point that actually
being thorough about it not just having
the name or what it would do but saying
you gotta have a you gotta have a good
commercial name something you think it's
gonna sell you have to describe it you
have to give it a price you have to have
any kind of like particular export
restrictions that might apply you might
need to normalize it
in two different currencies it might
have different prices based on what part
of the world was made at you take you
take all the themes that people think
about today like how much of this is how
much of it is a is a crowd-funded idea
so someone's saying this is the product
if you pay if you pay for it now you'll
get it in six months or if you pay for
it now as we know I mean now it's it's I
mean I buy my clothes from a place
that's like if you if we get enough
money will actually make your shirt
which is which is fantastic but also you
know otherworldly but you know playing
those kinds of themes out and evolving
them and so here are some of the things
so the child follow flying a veces is a
time when drones were still like wow how
super cool now they're kind of like
everyone's got them but like there would
be a drone that like follows your kid
and maybe even like kind of punishes it
if it's kind of sulking a drone that
would walk your dog like these are
things at the time was just you know and
now looking at it it's like it was only
a few years ago well it's kind of like
yeah it probably exists and we actually
had people say I'm like hey but do you
guys know that already exist so you're
catalogues it's like that's not
the point we're not trying to predict
things we're trying to just sort of
represent the completeness of a world in
which all these things that we're
excited about now were in a SkyMall
catalog or were the kinds of things that
people order three of because I might
break one or lose one
oh yeah like Bitcoin mining was huge so
people are just telling it selling just
like you know chips they'd just do
that but routinely I'm not a big extra
thing as to there's a dog walker drone
implications for like you know just even
even putting in that something is made
in Costa Rica people be like huh like
that's not a source of major
manufacturing particularly of consumer
electronics but like in a world in which
it was that gets people thinking about
how manufacturing is constantly evolving
and shifting yet fitbit's were
huge so this thing would actually shake
your Fitbit because somehow fitbit's
were attached to the price of your
health insurance was a little bit of a
kind of dodgy situation no one wants
smartphones anyone they just want funds
that are slightly clever and so with
genja understanding because smart is
like a bit of an ocular we assume what
it means but like suppose that evolves
and shifted and someone came up with
this they might they said like actually
clever is a new thing clever is is sort
of like it's like the thing knows what
to do but it's maybe a little bit of a
smart ass about it which you know you
can imagine artificial intelligence is
coming to that point where it's not just
like it's not just you know if you think
you know Siri or Alec's or Pleasant has
a little bit of attitude like that Panda
jerky says people panda jerky what are
you talking about we imagine a world in
which actually what happened is they
managed genetically to get pandas to
reproduce brilliant but then they over
produced and now the fear all and
they're all over the place they're like
you know like bears and Jackson Wyoming
basically walking up to your house
opening the door coming in and stealing
your food so people like we're gonna do
now and so like I know we'll do we'll
call them and mold jerk their meat and
we'll sell it and you think I'll work
people like brilliant I know it's
horrible
everyone wants Big Data so now they're
little service companies that go around
like enlarging data for you know data
type is too small
completely algorithm Khalid generated
films so you basically say I want a
little bit of action there should be a
bank robbery a car chase and about 10
percent romance blink oh there's my film
fantastic and part of that was just you
know films can be formulaic and you kind
of like I could have done that was I
know the plot structure and it's just
basically your freshener was my favorite
like the a world in which because kids
are you know coming out doing a lot of
interaction with visual screens that
actually a kind of aphasia evolves and
develops we
they have trouble processing speech
because they don't have that kind of
interaction that you normally have with
like one-on-one dialogue and so this is
just sort of an evolving kind of
behavioral trait and so you have to have
these kind of air freshener devices that
I don't know what they do but it's more
the idea that there would be this
aphasia poor kid and so this is you know
so this is the work so just to kind of
take those ideas and then just do the
work of like kind of representing what
that might look like as a very complete
kind of product catalog sort of
implications notes and as another you
know again one of these archetypes yep
make it into a thing put it on the
Internet and sell them did the same
thing with IKEA and that's it thank you
[Applause]
where you see the design space of
critical designers and design futures
and kind of I mean I sort of see you
know on one end of positivism of things
like apples knowledge navigator things
that come from from companies where
they're trying to create this vision of
what the future could be and maybe on
the other end to still be in future like
it black near or other things but it
seems like in your own work the role of
Sacher ISM and maybe even camp comes
into play and wonder if you could talk a
little bit about where you see inside of
this space of design fiction and what
you think you know it is there something
that you think is more effective and
actually getting points of transfer or
is it important to have a different
perspective
it's definitely Porton to have different
perspectives so you know a given that's
that's that's assumed I think for for my
own practice and I think other you know
within within the new fish laboratory I
find humor at some level incredibly
effective and largely because it's if
you can have that if you can have that
that that break from like instrument you
know like like intellectual pragmatism
to just say like yeah actually it's a
good one that's good
and it's a cognitive thing that allows
you again I think - you know enter that
into that realm of like okay I'm gonna
accept this challenge and I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna engage in this because
actually those guys look like they're
having fun I want to be over there doing
what they're doing as opposed to you
know anything that where it almost seems
like a burden to address a problem and
the problem might be something of such
you know ponderous weight that you can't
even get your head around it because
you're like oh I can't fix that and
that's another reason to focus on the
normal ordinary everyday it's like you
just get down to that thing where it's
like I understand that I understand that
that that you know that constrain
problem space for climate collapse
environmental you know degradation I can
I can understand what that means that
it's like for what my commute might look
like in the morning so I can begin to
show that and represent that and even
you know you try to find the way to do
it so that it does feel like there's a
point of entry for people to kind of you
know just come in and you know even if
it's like gallows humor find the way to
say it like okay so now we can talk
about now we're all like it's easier I'm
just I'm personally I'm naturally drawn
to
[Music]
and then we were imagining the future
how did you factor the past yeah it's a
good question I'm not sure the exact
answer but there was one project that we
did where we actually it had it had your
two main chapters one was the past and
so we took as our kind of defining
problem like take the take the
innovations you know innovations that we
take for granted today and treat them as
if they belonged in a museum of the most
amazing things ever and so and we
started again after at the 99-cent store
so like the corner bodega or the court
you know the corner convenience store
and we let you said you know fire like
the fact that you can go and you can get
a lighter in in 20 different colors
there was a time of you would have been
like what like I can have portable fire
I don't need to like strike a stone you
know or like you know Cowboys out in the
West it's like they have to like go get
kindling and trying to get something
maps which we take for granted but you
were talking about like you know it if
there was a there's a time when like
maps were only the provenance of like
sea captains and like kings everyone
else was kind of like you have to ask
directions and those kinds of things and
so I think you know almost almost like
translating something that you you
expect to exist or you think or maybe
possibly or you want to show what it
would be like in the future but then
kind of like normalizing it is one way
so I think you know the the cyclic ality
thing I don't know you know
it's it's a so I you know it's complete
digression but so I I started a company
that's making a bicycle computer so this
is a bicycle computer really is got GPS
and all those kinds of things
but as an analog display a mechanical
display and this for us wasn't because
we wanted to be retro and it wasn't
because we wanted to pull something in
the past it's just like a better way of
seeing information when you're doing
something mechanical anyway it's not
just like a data display it's like you
know you pedal harder and something
moves which is much more pleasing than
anything else so I think thinking about
ways in which things that existed in the
past
were not they weren't they didn't exist
there because no one knew any better
they existed there for like a reason and
a purpose and so to take your example
about you know the size of phones or
screens or that kind of thing
is almost you know related so like
understanding that trajectories you know
it's a pin things are pendulum right so
they go one way and they come back
another way and like life and politics
and Society and technology and those
kinds of things and so imagining that
the thing that someone might say is
highly unlikely like we'll never go back
to analog mechanical displays the
mechanical watch industry is going
gangbusters I mean they're like you know
just I'm a bit of a watch aficionado and
they're people making watches that you
would that anyone else would say like
that will not exist in the future
because everything will be on a bit
digital display and apples coming out
with an eye watch anyway and they're
gonna rule the world which doesn't
happen and so you find those ways in
which you take something that existed in
the past
bring it back into the you know into
your representation of a design fiction
and get people to talk about it and ask
a question and respond to it and have
those examples of the ways in which
understanding that the future isn't just
up in to the right things just don't go
that way
all the time they just kind of like
you're saying have these evolutions and
these revolutions
you
[Applause]